on capitol hill this morning a new
select committee on the january 6
attack is holding its first public
hearing witnesses include
law enforcement officers who were on the
front lines that day
under attack from a pro-trump mob nicole
killian is on capitol hill nicole good
morning
good morning anthony each of these
officers has spoken out publicly before
but this is the first time we will hear
from them collectively
committee members say they believe they
are a representative sample of what
police experienced on january 6 and hope
it counters
any attempts to try to whitewash what
happened
this morning raw unfiltered testimony is
expected about the brutal battle to
defend the capital
january 6. i was tortured
i was beaten
i was you know struck with a taser
numerous times
at the base of my skull and i posed no
threat
[Applause]
metropolitan police officer michael
fanon is among four
officers testifying as the house select
committee convenes its first hearing
investigating the attack a really
important opportunity
to remind everybody about
the necessity of accountability for what
happened
wyoming republican liz cheney is one of
only two republicans on the panel
mocked by the head of her own party for
serving
who is that adam and liz aren't they
kind of like pelosi republicans
the war of words between speaker nancy
pelosi and minority leader kevin
mccarthy
spiraled after pelosi rejected two of
mccarthy's five picks to serve on the
panel
but he pulled all of them and pelosi
appointed illinois republican adam
kinzinger
instead do you worry about being
punished what's the punishment that can
happen
if kevin decides they want to punish you
know liz cheney and i for
getting to the bottom and telling the
truth i think that probably says more
about
them than it does for us has this gotten
too ugly too politicized
it's our obligation to find the truth as
the select committee moves forward
some house republicans including those
booted from it want to change the
narrative
they'll attack president trump just like
they did when he left office and still
impeached him
so they'll do the same old thing this
all comes against the backdrop
of the upcoming midterms the committee
has not said
how long its probe will last but will
follow the facts
wherever they lead even if it means
calling up
leader mccarthy or possibly former
president trump who has blasted this
panel as
fake and highly partisan anthony nicole
killian thank you nicole